[Musique]
nous pouvons être fiers des grands
chantiers que nous menons en faveur de
la transition écologique et solidaire
aujourd'hui nous département voulons
aller encore plus loin
nous adoptons un grand plan de
transition écologique et solidaire qui
nous permettra de faire notre part dans
cet immense défi face aux dérèglements
climatiques à la perte de la
biodiversité à la pression sur les
ressources naturelles face aussi à
l'opportunité d'évoluer vers une société
plus solidaire et plus sobre le
département s'appuie sur l'ensemble des
réunionnais pour trouver des solutions
1067 proposition ou émerger de la
concertation organisée en octobre
novembre 2020
elle constitue aujourd'hui le socle de
ce plan de transition de la feuille de
route du département pour contribuer
plus et mieux aux défis du développement
durable c'est l'ensemble de
l'administration qui transforme ses
pratiques pour que les préoccupations
environnementales soient pleinement
intégré à notre fonctionnement
nous diviserons par deux la quantité de
déchets non recyclables générées par
notre activité d'ici 2025 nous
expérimenterons au sein des directions
volontaire plusieurs actions de
réduction des déchets non recyclables
grâce au partage d'expériences et en
s'adaptant à chaque situation spécifique
nous généraliserons les actions les plus
pertinentes
les élus et les agents n'ont pas attendu
la mise en place d'un plan de mobilité
pour laisser leur auto à la maison ça
fait cinq ans que je prends le bus pour
venir travailler
donc c'était des économies déjà on n'a
pas d'essence à canada dépensé on n'a
pas de voiture a fait des révisions
lassus c'est super pour n'a rien à dire
aujourd'hui entre et non l'ensemble des
agents et élus dans une mobilité plus
durable en se déplaçant moins et mieux
en 2023 nous souhaitons que 500
personnes du département et évoluer vers
un transport moins polluants grâce par
exemple à une plateforme de covoiturage
nos achats doivent entraîner les
entreprises de la réunion vers de
nouvelles technologies et façon de faire
pour cela nous visons en 2026 un
objectif de 50 % de marché comprenant
une clause environnementale dans un
dialogue constant avec le monde
économique
[Musique]
m
la nature et les paysages de nos cirques
et remparts sont au coeur de notre
identité pour préserver et valoriser
notre biodiversité nous replanterons un
million d'arbres d'ici 2024 et nous
menons une politique offensive pour
protéger nos forêts des espèces
exotiques envahissantes
preuve qu écologie et développement
durable peuvent travailler main dans la
main nous réaménagerons nos espaces
touristiques emblématiques comme le pas
de bellecombe et le maïdo nous engageons
une transition agricoles pour nourrir
tous les réunionnais avec des produits
frais locaux issus de l'agriculture
raisonnée biologique ou de
l'agroforesterie dans les prochaines
années
cela signifie créer un label de
reconnaissance des produits péi 80% des
fruits et légumes et 95 % de la viande
fraîche seront produits localement 5
millions d'euros sont réservés au
développement du bio sur les cinq
prochaines années nous favorisons
l'alternative à la voiture en
développant en cohérence avec les autres
collectivités
les pistes cyclables pour garantir la
continuité des itinéraires un grand plan
vélo qui définira les travaux à réaliser
et les services de mobilité douce à
mettre en place sera mise en oeuvre
nous adaptons notre réseau routier au
dérèglement climatique et à
l'intensification des cyclones grâce à
la sécurisation de 156 radier nos
bonifions nous aide en faveur des
projets de l'économie circulaire et
mettons en réseau tous les acteurs de ce
domaine pour créer un véritable effet de
levier de diffusion sur le territoire
[Musique]
la transition écologique doit être
solidaire elle nous associent tous pour
que chacun puisse y contribuer mais
également qu'elle profite à chaque
réunionnais et réunionnaises faire des
économies en faisant des l'écologie
c'est possible et nous le montrerons en
proposant à nos publics des ateliers de
confection de produits ménagers de
redécouverte des pratiques longtemps de
cuisine pour limiter le gaspillage nous
associons tous les réunionnais à ce
grand mouvement grâce à un plan de
sensibilisation qui intègre aussi les
plus jeunes dans les crèches
établissements scolaires établissements
d'accueil d'enfants ou de jeunes adultes
parce que nous ne pouvons rien faire
seul nous mobilisons et appuyons nos
partenaires pour développer des actions
conjointes de transition écologique et
solidaire
la réussite du plan de transition
écologique et solidaire repose sur notre
capacité à organiser une gouvernance
moderne et transparente la gouvernance
associer des citoyens les élus les
agents les partenaires publics et privés
tous ceux qui ont un rôle à jouer dans
la transition la gouvernance s'appuie
sur des indicateurs régulièrement mise à
jour est communiqué dans un espace dédié
la transition écologique et solidaire
est un sujet complexe et ses outils nous
permettront d'adapter notre stratégie
pour répondre au mieux aux attentes du
territoire vous le voyez les actions à
mener sont nombreuses et les défis
immenses photo ac soit la fée nature
ball en sort n'a donne l'exemple qu'ils
soient d'un secteur social qui soit dans
l'économie ou sinon ça pour prothèses
nous de l'environnement nous va faire un
sort aux bonnes plantes et égayent
vivent bien il plante tout sept nuls a
besoin manger manger local est bonne
plantations pays
bon pour notre santé bon pour notre
porte monnaie aussi notre cerveau
poussée tient toute façon de faire
autrement sans gaspillage trup gones if
you l'az partage de tours n'a mettent
ensemble pour soutien nouveau filière
aussi plage ici même dans tout service
département la forme à nous n'a fait
loterie la recycler nouveaux prêtres la
main toute bonne intercommunalités vous
trouvez un bon solution protège banzio
nadal fava n'a donne la main des actions
plantations pieds de bois local nassogne
ban animaux endémiques
nouveau regroupe toutes bonnes d'aumône
à terre dans l'économie dans le social
autour notre mouvement la transition
écologique et solidaire comme ça nous
toutes les gagnants la population bonne
travailleurs aux nouvelles formes de
monde explique azote que saleh est
urgent les grappes notre planète que ça
le climat y est sauf
c'est pou ça nous va facilite tout bénef
pour fait accélérer le changement nous
verrez d'huisne une quantité d'émissions
carbone si nous département nous va
développe de transport en commun
déplacement vélo à pied ça qu'apple
déplacements doux
[Musique]